>> Laura: TIME NOW FOR THE
SEEN AND THE UNSEEN SEGMENT
WHERE WE EXPOSE WHAT IS BEHIND
THE BIG CULTURAL STORIES OF
THE DAY.
WHY FACEBOOK WANTS YOU TO SEND
THEM YOUR NUDE PHOTOS.
I CAN'T BELIEVE WE'RE DOING
THIS SEGMENT.
HERE TO EXPLAIN THIS IS THE
"NEW YORK TIMES" BEST SELLING
AUTHOR OF THE CHILDREN SERIES
AND THE FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
RAYMOND, WHAT IS THE STORY?
FACEBOOK WANTS YOUR NUDE
PHOTOS?
>> THEY WANT YOUR NUDE PHOTOS.
PREEMPTIVELY.
>> Laura: WHY DO PEOPLE HAVE
NUDE PHOTOS?
>> THAT IS A BIGGER QUESTION.
THEY WANT TO FIGHT REVENGE
PORN WHERE PEOPLE IN
RELATIONSHIPS POST NUDE
PICTURES OF THE PARTNER WHEN
THE RELATIONSHIP ENDS.
>> Laura: WHO ARE THESE
PEOPLE?
>> I BET WE COULD NAME A FEW
BUT WE WON'T.
THEY WANT YOU TO SUBMIT YOUR
PHOTOS, THE MOST SECRETIVE
PHOTOS YOU HAVE TO FACEBOOK.
THEY THEN ENCRYPT THEM, THEY
TAKE WHAT THEY CALL A
FINGERPRINT OF THE PICTURE SO
NOT THE PICTURE THEMSELVES.
THEY SAY THEY DON'T STORE IT.
IT WILL BE OFF THE SERVER IN A
FEW DAYS AND THEY WILL BLOCK
THAT IMAGE EVER POSTED ON
FACEBOOK.
HERE IS THE PROBLEM, LAURA.
WHO IS LOOKING AT THESE
IMAGES?
HOW LONG ARE THEY ON THE
SERVER?
THE BIGGER QUESTION FACEBOOK
HAD A 50 MILLION PERSON BREACH
LAST YEAR THEY ADMITTED TO.
IN MARCH.
THEY ADMITTED TO THIS.
HOW SURE ARE WE THEY CAN
PROTECT THE IMAGES AND THAT
THE EMPLOYERS ARE NOT
CATCHPYING THEM -- COPYING
THEM?
>> Laura: WHAT IF OTHER
PEOPLE HAVE OTHER NUDE PHOTOS.
THIS WHOLE THING IS -- FORGET
"SEEN AND UNSEEN."
WE'LL CALL THIS THE END OF THE
CIVILIZATION SEGMENT.
TOMMY, MAKE A NEW GRAPHIC.
TOMMY IS LIKE I DON'T MAKE
GRAPHICS.
>> WE SHOULD MOVE ON.
>> Laura: A NEW YORK MAN WHO
IS 30 YEARS OLD.
>> MY GOSH.
>> Laura: SUED HIS PARENTS
OR SUED BY HIS PARENTS.
WE CALL THESE PEOPLE BOOMERANG
BATS.
YOU THROW THEM OUT TO THE
WORLD AND THEN THEY COME BACK
AND STAY AT HOME.
>> A 30-YEAR-OLD WHO SAYS
LOOK, I'M TRYING TO BE A
FATHER.
HE HAS A CHILD OF HIS OWN.
I'M TRYING TO BE A FATHER AND
I NEED TO LIVE WITH MOM AND
DAD.
THEY GAVE HIM FIVE NOTICES TO
GET OUT.
FIVE EVICTION NOTICES.
THEY DEPRIVED HIM OF FOOD.
>> IS THAT HIM?
>> HE SAT WITH ANOTHER NETWORK
AND SAID THIS.
>> Laura: DO WE HAVE THE
AUDIO?
>> WHY COULDN'T YOU GUYS
RESOLVE THIS WITHOUT THE
COURT?
>> I WOULD CONSIDER MUCH OF
WHAT THEY WERE DOING TO TRY TO
GET ME OUT AS ATTACKS.
>> A THIRD OF MILLENNIALS ARE
AT HOME WITH THE PARENTS.
>> Laura: ATTACKS?
HOW ABOUT GET A HAIRCUT?
IT LOOKS LIKE COUSIN IT.
THAT WAS SCARY.
>> HERE IS THE SCARY THING.
A THIRD OF THE MILLENNIALS ARE
>> Laura: LOOK AT HIM.
>> THIS HAS GONE UP FROM 25%
TO 34%.
>> Laura: HE IS STROKING HIS
HAIR.
HE DOESN'T HAVE MONEY FOR
HAIRCUT.
>> TOUGH TIMES.
>> Laura: IF YOUR KID IS
THREATENING TO COME HOME AFTER
HE WENT TO COLLEGE OR
SOMETHING TURN THE ROOM TO A
HOME GYM WITH NO COUCHES OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
>> THEN THE JUDGE ORDERED
THEM -- THE JUDGE RULED THAT
THE KID HAS TO VACATE, THE MAN
HAS TO VACATE.
AND THEY ARE CALLING FOR AN
INVESTIGATION BY ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES.
I HOPE THAT IS FOR THE PARENT
AND NOT FOR THE SON.
NOW THE BIG STORY OF THE
NIGHT.
>> Laura: STORMY DANIELS IS
GETTING A KEY TO WHAT?
>> NO, TODAY SHE GOT THE KEY
TO THE CITY OF WEST HOLLYWOOD.
THIS IS THE MAYOR JOHN DURAN.
LISTEN.
>> AS YOU KNOW, LADY GODIVA
RODE NAKED THROUGH STREETS OF
ENGLAND TO PROTEST INJUSTICE
IN TAXES AND WE HAVE OUR OWN
LADY GODIVA IN THE CITY OF
WEST HOLLYWOOD.
SHE HELD HER HEAD UP WITH
DIGNITY AND SHE FOUGHT BACK.
WHEN SHE FOUGHTS BACK AND
MR. AVENATTI FIGHTS BACK, THEY
ARE FIGHTING BACK FOR ALL OF
US TO GET THE COUNTRY BACK
INTO OUR HANDS.
>> Laura: DID HE USE THE
WORD "DIGNITY"?
DO YOU SPEND A LOT OF TIME IN
WEST HOLLYWOOD?
>> THEY HAVE ASKED FOR
IMPEACHMENT FOR TRUMP.
>> Laura: IMPEACH THE MAYOR.
>> NOTHING SAYS YOU ARE
HONORED LIKE GETTING THE KEY
TO THE CITY IN FRONT OF A SEX
SHOP OWNED BY A DRAG QUEEN
PORN DIRECTOR.
THIS IS THE LEVEL OF HONOR
BESTOWED ON STORMY DANIELS
STAND GREAT STAR RE -- AND THE
GREAT STAR REACTED THIS WAY.
>> I'M NOT SURE WHAT THE KEY
OPENS, I'M HOPING IT'S THE
WINE CELLAR.
THIS COMMUNITY HAS A HISTORY
OF STANDING UP TO BULLIES AND
SPEAKING TRUTH TO POWER.
I'M SO VERY, VERY LUCKY TO BE
PART OF IT.
>> YOU KNOW, THEY SAID SHE WAS
A PROFILE IN COURAGE.
SHE IS A PROFILE IN CLEAVAGE.
I HOPE THE KEY OPENS THE DOOR
TO TALBOTS SO WE HAVE FULL
COVERAGE.
>> Laura: I THREW MY BLUE
CARD IN THE AIR.
>> WE DIDN'T TALK ABOUT THE
NFL POLICY.
NO KNEELING, $20,000 PENALTY
IF A PLAYER DOES IT FOR THE
CLUB.